So first let's find the average of all these values. You can see that the values
go all the way to 101. Since there's not a value in cell a1, there are 100
values. So here, we'll write equals average, a2, through a101. That gives us the
average. Now here, we type a2 minus whatever we got for the average, which is
our deviation. So equals, a2 minus 50,586.36. I usually like to round it to two
decimal places. Make sure that you don't put in any commas. Now, we drag this
down, all the way to cell b101. And now we have each deviation from the mean, so
remember, this is xi minus x bar. Now we're going to square each deviation.
Equals, b2 squared. And again, we're going to drag this all the way down. Now we
can find the average of the squared deviation, which is the variance. So we
write equals average c2 colon c101. So now we have the variance. And finaly, we
take the square root of the variance to find the standard deviation. Equals SQRT
of cell f1. And you always kjow if you are using the right cell, if there is a
dotted line highlighting it. So here it is. You should have gotten approximately
10,657 for your standard deviation. Due to rounding, there is a range for
answers that were correct in this quiz. Good job! This is really tough stuff.
And actually, this is probably one of the most complicated calculations that
you'll have to do throughout the rest of this course.